ام
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله سقط قتلى وعشرات
الجرحى في اشتباكات اندلعت بين انصار
المرجع الشيعي اه محمود الصرخي الحسني في
كربلاء والديوانيه وبين قوات تابعه لرئيس
الوزراء نوري المالكي هذه المواجهات تعبير
عن تصعيد الملحوظ في حده الصدام الى
المالكي وعدد من الاصوات الشيعيه التي
تتهم ه بانتهاج سياسات طائفيه نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما وجهت
الاتهامات ب تاجيج الطائفيه الصادره من
داخل البيت الشيعي اتجاه المالكي
وما مدى تاثير الانتخابات الشيعيه على
حظوظ المالكيه السياسيه
يوما بعد اخر و نبره الاصوات الشيعيه
المعارضه لرئيس الوزراء العراقي نوري
المالكي تعالوا اكثر فاكثر يلتقي في هذا
قيادات سياسيه على غرار مقتضى الصدر وعمار
الحكيم و مرجعيه دينيه مثل الصرخي الحسني
بكربلاء ناهيك عن ما يعتبرها البعض رسائل
الاستياء مبطنه من المرجعيه العليا ايه
الله علي السيستاني الى المالكي هؤلاء على
الخلاف في المواقف السياسيه فيما بينهم
يتفقون على ان السياسات التي ينتهجها
المالكي في حال استمرارها كفيله بتقسيم
الشعب العراقي ودفعه ربما الى حرب اهليه
لا تحمد عقباها
تداهم قوات المالكي مكاتب المرجع الشيعي
الصرخي الحسني في كربلاء والديوانيه
فيشتبك مناصروه معها فتكون نتيجه قتلى
وجرحى في صفوف الطرفين تقوم قوات المالكي
بما هو اكثر تقصف انصار الرجل بالمروحيات
اذرعتها ان الحسن يسعى الى تاجيج الوضع
الامني في كربلاء ياتي هذا كما تقول بعض
المصادر بعد رفض الرجل فتوى ايه الله
السيستاني الاخيره الداعيه الى القتال على
ان الخلاف على اهميه الرجل من عدمها لا
ينفي براي كثيرين وجود تشققات في الصف
الشيعي ان لسبب فقهي او لاسباب سياسيه
وظهرت هذه الانقسامات وتوحشت في الولايه
الثانيه لرئيس الوزراء نوري المالكي
ف اكبر الكتل الشيعيه في البرلمان بقياده
مقتدى الصدر وعمار الحكيم
اصبحت تجاهر بالخلاف مع المالكي ووصل الحد
الصدر الى اتهام المالكي بتهميش السنه
ودفع البلاد الى ما لا تحمد عقباه
وفي خطاب شهير القاه قبل ان يعلن اعتزاله
العمل السياسي وصف الصدر المالكي بالطاغوت
وذهب وعمر الحكيم الى رفض الدخول في تحالف
يمنح الرجل ولايه ثالثه ولم ينجح المالكي
في تسويق خطر المسلحين ومنهم مسلحو الدوله
الاسلاميه في دفع هؤلاء وغيرهم الى تغيير
موقفهم لصالحه فاخر اجتماع لمجلس النواب
كشف عن انقسامات العميقه بين تيارات
المكون الشيعي بسبب اصرار المالكي على
تولي منصب رئيس الوزراء فبعض هذه التيارات
علمانيه النزعه كان ولازال يرفض ترشيح
الرجل وانتقل الامر الى المرجعيه العليا
ممثله ب ايه الله علي السيستاني الذي اكثر
ممثلوه في الاونه الاخيره من الدعوات الى
تشكيل حكومه موسعه تنهي المظالم في البلاد
ما فهم منه على نطاق واسع ان الغطاء بات
يسحب عن الرجل من مكونه كما من حلفائه
السياسيين داخل البلاد وخارجها
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت
الشيخ عباس الجوهري مدير موقع لبنان
الجديد ومن بغداد عبر سكايب محمد العجيري
عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون والحرب ضيفينا
الكريمين اه
شيخ عباس جوهري اه قوات حكومه المالكي
تداهم اكتب ومقال اه
محمود الصرخي الحسني
والمالكي يتهم صرخه زعزعه الامن في كربلاء
بلد صحه ودقه هذا الاتهام
اولا اسعد الله مساءك واسعد الله مسائل
المشاهدين وتقبل الله اعمالهم في هذا
الشهر الكريم المبارك
في البدايه عندما نبدا من الحادث الذي حدث
في كربلاء وغيرها
ولا نريد ان ندخل في اهميه
الاسماء التي طرحت وعدم اهميتها ل نقول ان
الحكومه اليوم تمر في مرحله شديده التعقيد
ولديها اه و عليها اعتراض كبير من البيت
الشيعي ومن المكون الشيعي وهذه الحكومه
التي لا تحظى بتاييد
كبير وبدا يتغير الى اوساط المرجعيه
الدينيه الكبيره في النجف الاشرف قد يكون
هو العامل الاساس في توجيه الانظار نحو
المعترضين على السياسه الحكوميه بانهم سوف
ينالون او سوف يتعامل معهم بالشكل الذي اه
تعاملوا مع صرخه اه اه اليوم اه انا اخشى
ان الحكومه تهرب الى الامام اه من من خلال
هذه الاعمال وسواها لان الجو في العراق
اصبح ينكشف اكثر فاكثر عن الغطاء الذي كان
يحظى به اه السيد المالكي والحكومه
العراقيه التي
يعني لم تقدم الكثير مما ينبغي ان تقدمه
للعراق للمحيط وتدخلت
بكثير من الملفات التي اوردتها هذه النقطه
الواسعه في الداخل والخارج
هذا الامر سيد عباس الجوهري
اه اه اسمح لي يعني قد يكون هذا الامر
مفهوما من قبل خصوم اه المالكي ان المكون
السني او مكان يكون قد يشتكي من سياساته
التي قد يرى فيها تهميش ولكن ان يكون ذلك
او هذه الاصوات تصدر من داخل البيت الشيعي
ما دلالات ذلك
اه في البيت الشيعي معارضه كبيره لحكومات
المالكي اه لم تبدا بالسرقه ولن تنتهي به
اه راي اه مقتضى الصدر السيد مقتضى الصدر
السيد عمار الحكيم الكثير من الشخصيات
العراقيه والنخب والمسؤولين في الدوله
العراقيه اه قدموا استقالتهم نحن لا ننسى
ان السيد عادل عبد المهدي قد قدم استقالته
اعتراضا على سير العمليه السياسيه في في
في العراق اه اه ال الكثيرون في البيت
الشيعي كانوا يتذمرون من اداء اه حكومه
السيد نوري المالكي وليست وليس هذا الصوت
الصوت الاول اه لكن التعامل مع هذا الصوت
بهذا الشكل من الحده والعنف والقتل وال
وال هجوم اه قد يكون مؤشر الى ان المالكي
يريد ان يفهم الجميع ان من يعترض على
الحكومه سوف اه يعني يلاقي المصير ذاته
هذا
الخاسره الرخوه
وهذا الامر لا يمكن ان يكون يعني هذا
بالضبط المعنى الذي ورد في بيان هيئه
علماء المسلمين في العراق التي نددت
باستهداف اه اه اه اه المرجع الشيعي محمود
الحسني الصرخي وقالت بان ذلك هو خطوه
مفهومه لواد اي تحرك لابناء الجنوب في
سبيل الانكار على الظالم ما ردك
سيد محمد غير على ذلك
نعم بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم مساء الخير
انا اعتقد يعني
يوم الظاهره
في اراضي من قبل او الغطاء السنين الشرعيه
الى مجموعه مجموعه اراده استفاد على مركز
للاسلام ان يكون هناك خلالها
وجودها
الثالثه من المجموعه الطرفين وهذا عن
القانون
وبالتالي التوجه وتمكن القوات السياسيه
المنطقه
السلاح ضد الدوله
هذا اليوم اعتقد على كثيره على الطرف ربما
هي منطقه
يعني مرحله
في اتجاهات
لا نتحدث فقط عن الصرخه هنا نتحدث عن هذه
الاصوات داخل البيت الشيعي الاصوات التي
صوتت لنوري المالكي او بات رئيسا للحكومه
وبفضل ها اصبح رئيس الحكومه هذه الاصوات
الان اصبحت تندد بسياسات ه يعني صار في اه
يعني ليس واحدا منها وانما هي اصوات كثيره
كيف نفهم من ذلك
ابدا يجب ان نميز بين ال الاعتبار السياسي
على السيد المالكي وبين الظاهرات او
المظاهر الدينيه والمقار الخارجه على
القانون في كل البلدان في تظاهره ثالثه
على الطالب على
عليها الجماعه خارج
والسيد المالكي يضرب كل من يقول القانون
شيعيا ام سنيا جنديا بريطانيا وهذه
الاغتيالات
قانون الجانب الجانب الثاني الاخوه الجانب
المعارضه السيد المالكي لو تمكنوا من
الاعداء الاغلبيه في البنك الشيء جانب اخر
المالكي لكن
الشعب
القاضي وكذلك
المالكي الوزراء
الابيض
وليس
في الموضوع من
الانسان الحضور اكثر من بعد ظهر اليوم
البلد في مواجهه
انه
الامام السيستاني والقوه
هذه
القوات
هذا الممكن من المسلمين ولكن اليوم كل من
لديه الاخر جانبيه في هذا الوقت انا اعتقد
من الطحين
مائه واربعين من الدستور
من السنه ان يركبوا
مع الموضع
الحكومه
حتى اقرار من بعض الشيعه الصرف او غير في
هذا الظرف الظاهر هناك
اليك يعني حتى اذا كانت
ما هي ماخذ كمان تم في البيت الشيعي على
المالكي تحديدا على يعني ما هو الماخذ
الرئيسي على في سياساته
اه اولا العمليه السياسيه التي
استمرت سنوات طويله بعد سقوط النظام لم
تفلح بنقل العراق اه الى الى مصاف الدول
التي تضع
على على مسار التقدم والازدهار والعراق
دوله دوله غنيه اه لديها قدرات و امكانيات
ماديه هائله ومعنويه ومن خلال اه نخ بها
اه لم تفلح هذه الحكومه التي اه توالت على
السلطه فتره طويله في احداث تغيير مهم اه
الفساد نسمع عن عن صور كثيره من الفساد
نسمع ان السيد اه ال المرجع الكبير السيد
علي السيستاني لم يكن راضيا على سير امور
وهو ابعد السياسيين ولم يلتقي باي من
السياسيين على مدى سنوات طويله
اه لكي لا يعطي الشرعيه لاحد في فيما يقوم
به وفي اخفاقات اليوم مع تعقيد المشهد ومع
دخول
الارهاب الجديد
وانا اسمي الامور باسمائها
يريد اه السيد نوري المالكي ان ياخذ من
داعش المنظمه التي هي ارهابيه في في في
سوريا والتي والتي والذي حتى المعارضه
السوريه اه تعارضها كما تعارض النظام
لانها تحمل فكرا ظلاميا شكرا
يعني غابه واندثر اليوم يريد المالكي ان
يقول اما ان تذهبوا معي للقتال هؤلاء
الارهابيين واما ان تكونوا في صفهم هذه
هذا ال هذه القسمه الحاده لا يمكن مكونات
البيت الشيعي ان تذهب مع المالكي في ما
يريد نعم اه خطوره هؤلاء الظلاميين الذين
هددوا النجف الاشرف وكربلاء وهددوا مكه
المكرمه اه سوف يكون
خطرهم شديدا على كل دول الجوار على كل
الدول في المنطقه وعلى كل ال ال الحكومات
في المنطقه
ام اما ان يكون نوري المالكي هو راس
الحربه في مواجهتهم فهو انا اعتقد انه لم
يعد باستطاعته هو ان يقود هذه المعركه لان
شخصيته لم تعد مؤهله لان اه سنينه الماضيه
التي قضاها في الحكم ولم تعطي صوره النقيه
عن العمليه السياسيه وعن الشراكه الحقيقيه
مع كل المكونات العراقيه هي التي اه تجعل
منه شخصا غير
قادر اه للنهوض بالمرحله الجديده المرحله
الجديده بحاجه الى شخصيه وحدويه نحن في
لبنان لدينا اه صوره مشابهه لما
حكومه شراكه وطنيه
في توزيع الوقت سيد الجوهري حتى يرد كذلك
محمد محمد
سمعتها السيدات الزهر يقول بان المالكي
يريد ان يوظف تطوره الامنيه الاخيره ليقول
البيت الشيء او المكونه الشيعي اما ان
تكون معي او ان تكون ضده رغم ان سياسته
الاقتصاديه فاشله السياسيه فاشله الامنيه
اه يعني زالت البلاد خطوره ويمكن ان تجعل
البلاد كلها بجميع مكوناتها بما فيها
المكون الشيعي يدفع الثمن
مع الشيخ عبد الله قوات الى الراي اه الى
ال اقول ان
في اه ولكن اي طبيب مع الشرطه
المالكي سياده وافق بناء مؤسسات دوله
حقيقيه
لكن الشركات مع المالكي ان يتعاملوا
بشراكه حقيقي وان كان هناك لا يتحمل
المالكي وانما في الجانب اللبناني
تصور ان
الفلسطينيه
انا اعتقد
الامر بالتالي بالتالي المالكي ان يضغط
على المركز الاعلامي والمالي كما تفضلت
على انه
المرجعيه لها
علاقه السيد
المرجع الماني
تنفيذ قال في البلاد
المسانده القوات اليوم القوات المسلحه في
المال لانه
القائد العام
الجانب الثاني انا اعتقد اليوم
حتى
ولا الدول المجاوره
الاردن
الساسه
يمكن ان
المعارضه ساعه
اليوم
انتقد منظومه
في هذا الانفجار كان هناك على سوريا ان
الاولى
الفرقاء السياسيه ان يذهبوا اعلام
سياسيا وسوريا لكنه لن يستطيع ان المركز
او في سوريا او في هذا المجال
ايضا اسمح لي ليس هناك ليس بمساله ان
المالكي قوي او مستوى ولكن هناك انت تعلم
جيدا ان هناك تاثير لنفوذ خارجي جعل
المالكي يظله في السلطه
ابدا ابدا لن يكون هناك
الاشكال
السعوديه الاطار
يعني انا
موضوع
الفاصل السيد سنناقش بعد الفاصل تاثيرات
الانتقادات الصادره من داخل البيت الشيعي
على حظوظ المالكي الان السياسيه في ضوء ما
اه المفاوضات او او او ال ال الحوار
الدائر الان بين القوى السياسيه رئيس
الوزراء ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش تصاعد حده الانتقادات
لسياسات المالكي من داخل البيت الشيعي
نرحب ضيفينا من جديد عباس الجوهري بيروت
ومحمد جيل من بغداد الشيخ عباس هناك من
يرى بان طبيعه الصدام داخل البيت الشيعي
الان واه الاصوات التي تقول تنادي بالوحده
الوطنيه وتعارض سياسه المالكي لها خلفيه
معينه في هذا الصدام وهو اه اه صراع على
الكراسي صراع سياسي بالاساس وليس الصراع
حول قضايا وطنيه لحظه كيف اه ترد على ذلك
ابدا ابدا الصراع اه ليس على السلطه
وينبغي ان لا يكون كذلك اه هناك صراعا
سياسيا
طبيعي ان يكون بين المكونات لها رؤيتها
لها استراتيجياتها لكل مكون له نظرته لكل
قياده في العراق لها نظرتها في في في
الامور وفي اه اداره الشان العام اه هذا
الصراع امر طبيعي وعادي في دوله يعني تضع
رجلا على على مسار الديمقراطيه
اه لكن من الخطا ان نعتبر ان كل من يعترض
على على حكومه المالكي اه يكون خارجا عن
على الدوله وعلى العمليه السياسيه في
العراق انا اعتقد ان اه ما قاله السيد
مقتضى الصدر وما عبر عنه السيد عمار
الحكيم
غيرهم من النخب العراقيه اتجاه سياسات نور
المالكي اه لا يريدون الا ان يضعوا الامور
في نصابها ان يصوبوا الامور وهذا حق لهم
وهذا يكفله الدستور العراقي و تكفله كل ال
العربيه السياسيه
ولكن حينما حينما سيصل الامر الى انه ربما
قد يصور المالكي وحلفاؤه ومن يقف وراءه
بان خروجه من الساحه قد يزعزع ويهدد
التحالف الوطني في هذه الحاله كيف سيكون
موقف مكونات التحالف الوطني او مكون بيت
الشيعي اذا كان المساله هذا التحالف
ومصيره مرتبطا ببقاء هذا الرجل
نعم اه يعني بقاء هذا الرجل او او خروجه
من السلطه عائد الى الاصوات التي يمكن ان
يحظى بها من الكتل العراقيه اليوم في
مشكله مع الاكراد لا يريدون ان يجدوا او
يمددوا او ان ياتي السيد المالكي بولايه
جديده هناك اصوات شيعيه تريد ان تبدل
وتغير حتى المرجعيه نفسها اشارت في كثير
من الاحاديث وكلائها اه انه لابد من
التغيير لا بد من ان ناتي باشخاص اه نغير
بهم الساحه ونغير بهم الصوره النمطيه التي
اعطيت عن العمليه السياسيه في اليوم هناك
مشكله اكبر من الخلافات ومن التقديرات في
المواقف والرؤى حول العمليه السياسيه هناك
خطر هناك الثلث العراق يخرج من سيطره
الحكومه المركزيه هناك مشكله لدى الاكراد
وطرح التصويت والغاء الماده مائه واربعين
من الدستور
هناك يعني كثير من الامور التي جعلت
الاولويه تسير باتجاه اخر من يواجه هذه
الخطوره من من من هي الحكومه من هو الشخص
المؤهل ان يسير ب حكومه مركزيه قادره على
تجاوز هذه الازمه السيد نور المالكي لم
يعد يستطيع ان يكون رجل المرحله القادمه
ان الانتخابات التي النيابيه افرزت اه
تقدما له وهذا التقدم بين هلالين اه يمكن
ان يكون عليه علامات استفهام انا اقول انه
لا يمكن مواجهه الارهاب ولا يمكن مواجهه
التشدد الذي حصل في الساحه العراقيه الاب
شخصيه جامعه وبحكومه الجامعه
هذه الشخصيه الجامعه او الشخصيه الوطنيه
المؤهله لكي توحد ال ال المكونات العراقيه
بشكل عام المالكي الان يواجه باعتراض
الاكراد باعتراض التيار الصدري باعتراض
المجلس الاعلى الاسلامي وباصوات اه اه
سنيه وغير ذلك اليس في العراق رجل حكيم
رشيد رجل قادر و مؤهل لقياده العراق الان
وباستطاعته توحيد العراقيين اليس هناك غير
المالكي في العراق
الرجل الحكيم في هذه المرحله هو السيد
المالكي الذي التقى ان يقف في وجه الارهاب
ولكن العراق الان الى هذا هذا
الثاني من البيت من البيت ال
عموما والان الاعتراضات فقط من مجموعه
السيد برزاني وانما هناك ايجابيا من
الاخوه في الحزب الاتحاد من
طالبان وهناك جماعه للتغيير
المالي جانب الجانب الثاني حتى في البيت
هناك مجموعه القوى السنيه تعيد
المالكي
رئيس الجمهوريه اما المعترضين انا اعتقد
كل هذه الاصوات
اسمح لي اسمح لي يعني انت
سمحت لك ان تعدد وتذكر بعض ال ال قام
والاشخاص ولكن هؤلاء ما حجم وزنهم لان
المالكي سياساته الان نتائجها واضحه على
ارض الواقع
يعني اي مصير ينتظر العراق اذا سلم العراق
مره اخرى للمالكي
سيدي الكريم مصير العراق كان ناجحا وجود
المالكي اولا الانتخابات السيد المالكي
للانتخابات البلديه الامر الامر المحليه
قبل
اولا المالكي
البلاد الى
وان كانت الجلسه الاولى ان هذه تعدوا
المالكيه اليوم مظهر الارض العراقيه من
الارهاب هذا هذه كلها انجازات
من ظهر المالي بالعمل السياسي هو من اجل
العراق يعني
كان فيها في الحساب الغاء مائه واربعين
هذه
كانت في البطن عندما قالت
اعضاء في النواب
هذه الالبانيه
المنطقه
يعني مستقبل المالكي بالنظر الى الجهات
والتيارات التي او تعارضه الان في العراق
المالكي بما يمثل
كبير له حضوره في الساحه العراقيه ولا
يمكن ان يختفي هذا الحزب باختفاء دور
المالكي شخص شخصيا المشكله ان المالكي اه
يعني اه جاءت اليه مشاكل عده اه المشك
المشكله الاولى دوره وتدخله في الملف
السوري المشكله الاخرى
عدم
استقطاب بالبيت الشيعي ومؤازره البيت
الشيعي له في سياساته اه الموضوع في
البيئه السنيه ال المصادر ان يخسر
لم لم يكن هناك اقصاء بالمعنى الدقيق ال
الطائفي وانما هناك اه في روحيه اقصاء
يعني الماضيين من البعثيين وما اشبه ذلك
الوقت انتهى الوقت والشيخ عباس جوهري مدير
موقع لبنان الجديد من بيروت شكرا لمحمد
تدعو الاختلافات قانون مشاهدي الكرام
ام